previously on monopoly plus a properties
over here by the big whale prop raise a
piece and bobs at six yes definitely get
that monopoly going oh my god you can
actually do that yes really bunch of
properties unbelievable what if what if
I proposed a big trade okay I'm
listening I give you both yellows for
both light blues but do you not agree
that having oranges and yellows this is
more beautiful whoa Oh what happened
what what happened you got all my stuff
what you just went bankrupt what
happened what No are you [ __ ] kidding
me I you what's up so [ __ ] much Bob
have you been totally demotivated from
this game kinda I know I get it I get it
I man that sucks the next turn I would
have had a play that you guys weren't
gonna believe I'll say the [ __ ] is
happening hey guys oh hello hey guys now
once we get a certain amount of
properties in here maybe we should give
Bob all the properties he had and
everyone will just oh no I'm gonna lose
just to show you be soft how much I hate
them well that was your same roll from
last time motivation is this my Samra
now I'm crushing it this is my game baby
I got a seven which is fitting for ya
yeah Bob get ready to suck on that
backed it hard it's still just a small
why are you playin small six did you try
hitting alt-enter yes I actually did you
could do it mark yes if this feels good
see this feels good be first out of the
gate and win this one getting properties
this feels good you would think that
until you see this amazing role number
one never mind just my routine from last
game you [ __ ] need to get back to
let's see what sort of garbage the game
gives me this marked property yes
goddamn it
yeah how does it feel $6 nice I don't
know anything about this
and I go right to jail yeah before you
go no the best one on the map on that's
gonna buy it excellent give me my third
set of pebbles so I get out of this
unending nightmare
come on boy whatever just whatever it's
not gonna help me anyway you're driving
by just chucking bags of money out the
window now take it I guess brah all
right I'm a solid bronze medal right now
everybody we're gonna we're gonna bring
it next round though just wait all right
yes I think Bob you and I were playing
the exact opposite game because I
started out with an orange and you
started out with a purple and a blue and
then weights just in jail I don't know
why he wasn't playing the game yesterday
yes I'm trying to be funny brooding okay
have a great game last game I'm having a
great game this game this is a great
time I didn't want the who I think you
went three octaves beautiful another
it's not all roses over here
stupid property now see the thing is you
were supposed to not get all the
properties this game cuz it was gonna be
a different game that's how the game was
going to be [ __ ] you both why'd you shut
up in your free parking we're out here
we're out here working hard for our
money in government funded Lots give me
give me look mark deserves this okay
developing his skills portfolio early
that's good wait oh wait me the money
wait no no yes no no I won't come I
won't do it I want the champ don't
little spaces around the corners with
the parking lots and everything that's
really confusing to my brain yeah well a
smart big brain people don't get so
confused you're gonna be a Titan of it
man be prepared to pay 20 you're gonna
be able to up charge people on soda pop
on the mains you're gonna be able to
turn off people's power just been just a
mess with them you got all the good
stuff going on man yeah yeah no Bob you
have the power thing no whatever I don't
care
[Laughter]
garbage land with some trees on it as
far as I'm concerned you [ __ ] from this
man this game is trying really hard to
make it up to me it's not that hard to
be a negative piece of [ __ ] about
something but this is really really
giving its weight and let it me have
anything I want
Park Place workplace park place that's
just came by to serve bits on your
ground poof Community Chest
maybe another property for Wade you can
walk baby mmm
all right let's pass go let's get a
couple hundred buckaroo knees oh that's
not a good number
wait now that'll be mine let's see
damming we shall say give it to me
advance the nurse railroad fun OD by the
[Music]
second is that your second one I saw
wait as the other one one property okay
okay I have so many properties I can't
even remember where they all are it's a
serious problem you know small numbers
Wade oh yes way do you need to land on
the properties properties
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
go back base where Oh rolling rolling
the monopoly guy is really helpful it is
it is wait roll the monopoly guy that's
good that's good no that's fine oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
Wow
you know what wait I appreciate you
trying sorry dude I cannot decipher his
rules what the hell does a little man do
little bit make him go to jail I command
it I went here you should really buy
someone property doubles you got doubles
doubles overrides the whatever the other
dice is for sale you can you can go to
the Reading Railroad that's not all is
this for sale we're gonna I'm taking
yeah yeah that's totally for sale no
worries second property hey that's not
as it's not even as good as a railroad
so I don't know what you're so excited
was the whole [ __ ] yeah
wait shut up Wade alright
little man little man mmm little man I
don't forgive you because you really
dict me over but maybe we can get past
this I think he just sent you backwards
so you could buy that property boss let
poopoo sunlit boot I can go five four or
one space or is Jail five is owned these
are all bad honest five is owned by you
at least is it oh good yeah that's green
right I for some reason thought that was
you and I was getting angry I am Blair
yeah you are Blair got him high five
wait BAM he's black like throwing up no
it can only be good oh it's that one
that I just bought that's really cool
thanks Wade hey calm down Jesus Christ I
can't wait relax very firmly in third
place I'll come close little man
bus bus oh my god I can move 11 squares
how the hell am I supposed to be able to
tell where 11 squares is it's the last
that's not owned I don't know why I'm
telling you no thanks for the help
mm-hmm I would have probably gone with
that anyway because they live who were
owned but one of them was mine mark you
and I are like unequal owners of to
settle bits there yeah it and
proportionally unequal to yes so
you guys tied for first I'm in second
place
no I'm on third that's not how that
works where am I but alas let me tell
you about my plans
- [ __ ] something else god you're right
you're right you're right you're right
you weren't even the first one in jail
and you got your money so calm down
right I am calm I was already in the
process of calming down I'm calming down
you can't tell me to calm down mark you
can't tell me to calm down
I was already calming I was already
coming it's already gone
believe me the waterworks you love
waterworks Huber were in my [ __ ]
family friendly Wade family friendly I
know a little man because I could have
got perk up horse Oh wah Oh No
whatever will you do yeah listen this is
a real hardship okay so don't tell mock
me on this one Oh pity for you oh you're
rude it's really rude of you mark to
mock me so it's Unown baby anymore I
don't know what anyone has to complain
about you all need to calm the hell down
did you see what happened to me last
time did you see what this game has done
to me you have no leg to stand on with
your position the new both games in a
row right now and how many properties
did I own when the game made me quit for
no reason about the same number of
properties as you own now little man
please look at who is Luck is turning
around right now
I've won you can't beat me five at a
time and it's a good
don't stop the guys or anything that's
for sale even oh there is I'll buy that
sure sure
you need one of these guys and I need a
Park Place what's trade I want someone
to I want something to map the the the
hit the pitch the pitch of your tone
from the beginning to the end of this
episode because it's steadily gone up
like you started no good take my money
Oh little man all Italy I want someone
to know mark yeah I've already gotten to
go to jail card so I should be we hope
for our friends yeah that's what we hope
oh don't be too Brown so doing some
Browns don't that's a keeper if this
could have started like six rounds ago I
might have a chance right now there's
still a couple things left to buy don't
fret what is left to buy I think one red
one green sold and the Browns known as
yeah yeah it's turned around your
construction site was not a very good
accommodation I just didn't like you
having four hundred and twenty dollars
I'm against drugs it's for twenty of the
drugs yes
where my baby yeah yes please baby well
well well well well well well anybody
interested in a trade
I like that yellow you got sin over
there you saying that orange I bet I bet
those two together might be similar in
value to the cost of the very fancy
green one that you want from that I
disagree entirely with that sentiment
but I bet they are well I know the green
one is the most valuable so I'm
definitely gonna need a little cash how
about to go on a Sonic the Hedgehog
spree Bob I wanted to pay you money here
you go thanks Sonic
yeah gotta go fast well I'll see what
happens here I'm just gonna give a smack
arou buzz I only got three three
movement points so I can go one two or
three cylinders that one oh no in its
own but this is uh known oh-oh I own it
but whatever I'm about to make some
moves gentlemen do wait never mind I
don't I don't want to go too sorry oh
wait oh wait I'm not desperate yet I am
desperate
oh man I almost got a little man or a
boss god forbid you know yeah this can
only be good things calories to fat brim
do you know
yes yes yeah what a Jones
if I have traded the green you would not
have earned that cash you are correct
sir
no I would have oh no I would have had
the green that's right no I would have
had the green oh I would but I would
have had like houses on that yeah you
was totally got me
he was totally showed me who's boss okay
alright okay I think I think I think I
think I think you know I just think Wade
get out of here you Bob let's go all
right we need to have a frank discussion
okay I can't let you have to monopolise
at once okay cuz I feel like that's just
no good for anybody especially way to
separate trades if that makes you feel
better don't worry about me
just enjoy him at all let's just say
let's just say for example if we were go
like this and let's just say let's just
say right sure no feel like that's fair
it's super fair super not fair super
fair super Nasser super fair super fair
very fair you a counteroffer very hmm
actually I can't do it
I'm really sorry I'll be right back just
say no then leave I think he's happy
oh I think he's gone I think he's gone I
think I should just like passed around
good yeah why are your biceps burnin it
said you're away for too long your turn
will be bypassed in 24 seconds I'm just
gonna end the turn you you take good
thank God I can stop take it or manage
property i'm in chat we have a Dora the
Explorer moment do I roll my dice or
manage properties roll quit declare
bankruptcy give up okay Chet thank you
for the sound advice oh there goes my
turn got a roll sure hope Bob's little
man hey that's a good rule I think
that's something bad no
no no no I might not be good at least
you're not giving money to one of your
opponents is what this [ __ ] had the
gall to say ty I heard it I sure hope
Bob's our where did Bob just gonna chat
I pay the 100 or throw my computer out
of my office
walk past it now I guess we're paying ah
good move good move
doubles good news Bob take your time Oh
[Applause]
this horrible monster of a game is
continuing from your pass go it'll be
great
I don't know if I can get doubles again
for you Bob but I sure will try all
right let's see it here we go I did not
little man you've gotta be nice hey
there's a thingy buy do I buy it
Moo good question wait think about it
I'll take my time what are the oh my god
I'm so sorry of a [ __ ] late cool but I
have like the most upset stomach today
I've had in like a year I'm totally back
now nothing about right now this I get
up in the real roof why did I miss
horrible things it seems fine yeah lots
of properties boss soon bus there's
nothing here of any away that's not sure
I can't go 4 spaces why couldn't I go 4
spaces she was better than chance I
think possibly unless you go to jail all
right buckaroo knees oh I have to hit
the button wall I was like ok I'm done
reading
nevermind little man don't matter all
right if Bob got good from ear surely I
will also get some good hey that's
pretty good
oh you're not up next loser so me take
you to property oh but I thought yeah it
had to be close that took him all the
way anywhere properties that takes you
to the nearest property that's not ok so
is there anything that's unknown anymore
one railroad the Browns the Browns are
brown the brown railroad all right Bob
we're in the middle of a no point you do
want to talk to you sorry I don't have a
spare change right now come on you were
you were about to accept this trade Bob
if I remember believe what I was in the
middle of doing something like this
hang on wait hear me out hear me out
hear me out
oh okay now that's not you know that's
intriguing right that's intriguing you
know that's not a bad deal I think we
got I think I think we got ourselves a
good deal that feels a little off no no
I think we got a good deal I think this
is good deal good deal good deal you
guys want to trade with me what do you
want what do you want what do you want
go away Bob you
made such an error who made such a
mistake I am going to do this oh those
are expensive here it's so pricey
they're very expensive these are so
expensive Jesus it's so pricey
don't worry mark I got money i mumble i
can't bother so pricey very pricey all
right where am I thank God oh this is
Bob's real world very impressive great
no no no turn [ __ ] do do it do it do it
do it roll like a 12 man could it be
could it be yes bucks 90 bucks just 90
bucks
weenie price well I mean it's a little
you need a little one house weenie baby
well okay well you know house man
talking to be mr. big house band
ooh look at that cool cool roll I did
that's a cool roll donkey slung dick
[ __ ]
listen let's see where it's weighed
about to be weights about to be over
here hang on TG baby one house son
that's what I thought ah I forgot mmm I
wish you luck
this is okay I don't need luck I've got
oh no
oh that's 20 bucks more than I bid you
it's ok still a little [ __ ] baby money
it's it's it's not real money it's not
real money give me the money yes yes yes
no little man where does that put you
now the other probably other three
railroads that's pretty good dude you
want a fourth railroad yeah Bob I'm
coming hang on
yeah you trying to play that railroad
industrial game and the other utility
for like boardwalk or something for just
casual you know like book or something
two things maybe just thing you know you
know like board Walker you ought to give
me all of your properties except Park
Place Wow well I mean values a little
skewed in your face there's a heck of an
offer I gotta say wait why I don't know
that's quite a play no good good on you
sir you're out here making moves and I
can't fault you for it yeah you know of
all of all the movies I was like you
know I can't can't be mad at that can't
be mad that can't be mad at that move
the hell of a move now if you could
please just not put any houses or hotels
oh well all right so it's a power play
it's a power it's a high risk oh my
that's high risk you know the difference
between three hours and four ounces is
not that much on those but you went for
it
you
okay Bob this game suddenly the
landscape has changed mark Hemans made
plays hi Bob you know suddenly I feel
very small dick energy here I feel
really dude wait you say that but you
say I got one for you guys around and
you just like land mines just appeared
on the board
I like we're running laps around the
board that was fun that was good I think
the games about start ending mark yeah 1
2 2 light blues for the purple
even-steven you know at this point it's
not really gonna make a difference well
I think we know who were against here
it's it's fine you know what wait if
it'll make you feel better if it'll make
you feel that doesn't make me feel
better look I thought you mean that much
it's just balance this is out a little
bit
all right fair's fair fair's fair
because then we have bigger problems in
the world like we're all equally rich
yeah you say that but you have like
three grand and houses sitting on your
property it's just because you know it
was either I risk it on there I just
give it to you so I risks oh I get to go
again raised boardwalk
change my life you could land on a red
that's not red that's not red at all
that's not that's not my property I I'm
totally I'm fine with this I'm happy you
know I hire stretch of board I feel
pretty comfortable in this area you know
there's other things besides owning it's
an aircard let's go directly to
boardwalk there sure is there sure is
yep there sure is all right all right
Wade you ready for moves cuz moves are
about to happen how many houses are 11
how many house they're left in the pot I
don't say that wait hold on just leave
one for me no no no no no no
drinking up all the house I'm so
bringing the juice tough there sulfur
half nuts so little money
my strategy where are you right now Bob
you're not even okay the red is like you
could land on the red touch my red touch
my red I just got to get these two three
houses so that I can get them you're
gonna land on this why don't you watch
as you hey we money when you get
absolutely dunked on right here you take
oh you son of a [ __ ] chick how you real
you do pay the bank or me or mark you
should definitely pay me you should pay
me house you might as well sell the
house to help friend you might as well
I'm afraid I'm a friend no no is that
for the railroad 50 bucks it's like 50
bucks is 50 bucks oh it's it's like 50
bucks
support me yeah what a friends she's
garbage is garbage so you got to sell a
house I think but you know
corner that bus my play would have
worked out really well okay let's just
all right owns the railroad what a fool
you're the one who bet everything on
boardwalk and Park plates I made a move
baby you're on your way you know Wade
I'm gonna remember this remember what
how I got my eyes kicking somehow lost
the - you still haven't horrible
decision to sell the wrong thing it was
such a bad play my ancestors are crying
for you the play to go from two to three
houses on a cheap property that you had
a probability of landing on yes that
play and that terrible horrible play can
still pay off I could roll it three or
four I know mark it might not have been
a bad plan all your [ __ ] talking won't
help you Frick I'm gonna die now now I
will die I just realize see a lot of
blue around that corner
this is that corner isn't all blue what
could go wrong you don't know that's not
gonna help me that's not gonna bail you
owe me 5050 is so easy peasy easy peasy
the difference between that is $80 the
difference between this is I get 50 but
I lose out on a possible sell one of
those now yeah exactly
I wouldn't summon it why am I taking
monopoly advice from you why am i
letting you criticize me at all bad luck
shush
thank you for the $50 I
Bob wait for you to roll again come to
my stretch come visit me oh please
please chance dreams for one yes you
have to [ __ ] oh I love it oh oh oh
that's two houses there you love to see
you you love to see it it's fine
I see the handedly prevented wait for
maybe winning yes yes your properties
were a bomb we if we made it all the way
over there and hit those you would have
bankrupt one of us all or you would have
basically stripped us of any income I
think I would have been straight-up
bankrupted Marco land and die you are
right but I don't think I'm gonna make
it past this orange and then the yellow
mmm Bob there's no way I'm never gonna
touch him Bob are you mommy are you mute
oh please be good to me please be good
to me four or six I'm good ways of
getting there without dude little man
makes no sense at all well how much do I
sell this for 25 and how much do I owe
you
I forgot to say oh you two seventy so I
could just do a couple of these bad boys
these Blues have paid in dividends and
so long as I don't land on your orange
please you owe me I don't owe you
anything nothing this much okay okay
okay okay I want you to do it I need
your power your power of not making
people hit on doing to help you he could
he could he could he could he could he
[Music]
where am I what's rule is just [ __ ] wait
I should have landed on 4 o'clock I
don't know these guys these guys are my
money makers I feel it I feel that these
guys are the ones well just pass through
I guess oh no no no no no god dammit
dammit I'm gonna give you a chance wait
it's already 20 now you can bid one
can't you no and I don't need it
I always forget about that I forget
about that every time about how the last
house needs talk it's all you buddy
go for it oh thank you enough fair
enough fair enough
College okay plop well you do have a lot
of houses over there yes yes this is
this is this is this is a bunt this is
the mice I'll make them no no because
right now no one else can buy houses
yeah cuz we're [ __ ] broke 13 bucks
you gotta be so careful right now with
this went for me feeling smug to me
feeling kind of mad no that's not a good
roll away that's not a good roll
my income tripled but whatever yeah
that's why he's bad all right well I
feel okay guys don't do it to me there
we go that's what I'm here for that's
the kind of content I'm here for what's
the lowest I could move - no no no - is
not what you would what you want six is
what you want
I own this property what a time to be
alive Wow
you know Bob I'm not gonna give you much
advice anymore if you don't take it oh
no so you know is that is that the
lesson I'm learning is that I should
take your advice yes
where's uh where's my buddies at oh
they're coming all right
they're they're coming how much is this
oh wow that's a lot no man no fool Oh
where'd those two oh you sold to us okay
yeah that's what I thought I'll just go
ahead and leave another one for auction
I guess I shouldn't have sold it but I
kind of probably need the money yeah
okay okay okay okay have fun
no don't roll too small of a number
we're on such thin ice right now it's
the thinnest ice I've ever seen a game
you can make it to your dreams oh yeah I
can yes I can
you didn't go to jail ah weird the
ultimate move oh you're right God that
would land on boardwalk next turn after
I land on one of your guys's properties
and get rid about my house it's wait to
get me do me do it it's not even that
much but it's enough to make him sell
it's enough to make himself oh that's
unfortunate how much do you like someone
- fine it's fine
you're mine - oh man there were four
houses there there were
there were boardwalk please you [ __ ]
okay low numbers low numbers that's some
big Oh what are you gonna do I don't
have no idea on that okay I can't do
anything cuz I'm power okay I need no
[ __ ] children to take you away from
me
what Oh interesting
that's not exactly a good thing what is
happening you get to pick where you go
you're picking where you go cuz I got
triple ones you got triple ones you get
to pick well any right now
oh my go to Pascoe and then no you won't
pass going well maybe you will I don't
know I don't go what what no I drag oh
god it's fine
I think that's probably still the move I
think it yeah okay Liz the move at the
moment alright it's fine it's fine
this is Wade fine better be careful man
you better roll me wash it that way
there's like a boardwalk down there oh
that's not very big money little man
little man wade in the middle where's
little man
[Applause]
no matter cuz I'm going to jail going
directly to jail it won't matter
ow I'm gonna go kill some I'm gonna go
stab someone about face find a police
officer tell them I found a child
trapped in a while bring them there and
then murder a child and throw the child
into the well anyway so you're saying
about a well and a child I didn't do it
I guess it didn't work out I guess I
murdered the child in the police officer
was like I didn't see anything you know
they didn't like that kid too bad cop
yeah that's a dirty cop mark please pay
the fine no pay fifty bucks why would I
do that why can I put a house down where
are you [ __ ] where are you houses
for you guys to buy smackeroonies to buy
some of those houses next to if these
blues somehow wouldn't be this game
that's gonna be
[Laughter]
come on with your friend Bob what the
Frick
Oh doubles oh wait what do doubles
always override the red the red doesn't
count
ah well whatever you'd pay me that 200
bucks that's all right oh no we sell a
couple of those houses buddy it's all
right and you have like four houses on
those remember those are good times look
now you have exactly what you need to
pay me basically
all right wait go go go yeah cool a
three I would just spar for even those
are big numbers you could sell and then
mortgage so you still have a house on
one that's fair that's what Bob land on
my blue Bob land on my blue I'm gonna
just no wetland on any of your stuff
just no thank you
blue please give me the 200 please I
like jail I love Jail
jail jail jail don't deal I did really
know the deal that was your best play to
possibly have a chance to win okay I can
do this I sold a house there but now I
have enough okay pay
Hey are you have to give after about
this time you have to come out and you
have it oh wait oh no but I'm okay over
here that's fine I'm totally safe over
here yeah let's hang out baby
what does the man do what does the man
do now why Oh what the [ __ ]
this is the rules of this don't make any
sense
doubles overrides everything little man
takes you to the next unknown property
until they're all owned the notation to
the next property that someone else owns
that's higher than whatever you were old
I think okay we have to leave now you
can't have any more I have to wait to
come out even if I roll I have to come
out I think so
Roland you don't get doubles you have to
pay the 50 anyway but you can race cool
I might as well I might as well right
ooh yes come on get out of there
I paid start paying me some money I
don't want to pay me the money I don't
want to I don't want to it's my money
yeah oh yeah well if you know who else
has money me and I will do these are so
expensive over here God but you should
definitely spend all that cash that'll
definitely benefit you no it won't even
be worth it because it wouldn't be
enough to get you it would just cost me
more than that
damn it keep that cash and save it for
me because you're gonna be paying it to
me hey you are gonna hit my blue would
you hit my blue that's very fancy very
fancy interesting Oh what oh hello we're
now playing with bots Vincenzo with your
stuff no hello I'm here
I'm here I'm here Oh No Vincenzo
Internet go out and I don't I'm here
hello hello he's spending all of your
money you have $66 he's spent everything
I'm in my game I'm playing with Iker and
also Vincenzo I landed on boardwalk Oh
potential inside
you see about this time out it's your
turn on my a-game bub no I'm watching he
already played on mine it's your turn
and you have like your property
management screen up what is what is
this gas game what is it what is this
actual piece of poop game I think that
Bob won wade pulled quite a move with
the boardwalk played almost worked out
for me it almost worked out I landed
right in between if I don't land there I
would have gone bankrupt if that little
Manhattan taking you away I know that
was so close Dixie and put a Big Bob
wins this is the most unsatisfying
report this game is just like the cheese
now what I know that was quite a fight I
really didn't think that game was gonna
go so well for you and it's just like
progressively got better and then rips
it away right at the end I didn't even
get the satisfaction of losing I did you
did how'd it feel
we should never play Monopoly
[Laughter]
[Music]